bonita traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray left
base one-seventh anita
in this video i'm going to show you
everything you need to know about making
good radio calls at non-towered
airfields bonita traffic skyhawk 3148
x-ray base to final 170 bonita
have you ever wondered why we talk on
the radios at non-towered airfields the
main reason we do it is to avoid hitting
other aircraft and we can do that by
being clear and concise when we talk to
other pilots on the radio and this makes
us predictable because everyone knows
exactly where we're at in the pattern so
today we're going to take a look at some
of the recommended communication
procedures and while it is true that
they're only recommended and not
required safety is everyone's
responsibility don't be that guy that
doesn't think you need to talk on the
radios it's not that hard and today i'll
show you exactly how to do it before we
can talk about that let's talk about
which frequency we need to use now it's
called the common traffic advisory
frequency or ctaf because we're advising
other traffic where we are in the
pattern and you can figure out which
frequency to use by either looking on
your vfr sectional or in your chart
supplement check out this airfield right
here called lawrence regional up here in
the information section of the airport
you'll notice this little c that stands
for ctaf and the frequency is right
beside it
123.0 and that's the frequency we're
going to use to make a radio calls but
notice this down here this towered
airfield also has a c beside their
control tower frequency and that's
because that little star beside the c
means that this control tower only
operates part time the rest of the time
that frequency turns back to a c taf so
when the towers close you make your ctaf
calls on
133.0 here now let's take a quick peek
over here in the chart supplement as i
mentioned before the tower only operates
part time and you can see the times here
when the tower closes the class delta
airspace reverts to class golf then once
that happens we'll make our ctaf calls
over on one thirty three zero now we'll
talk about how to make those radio calls
and the first step in doing that is to
find the name of the airfield where
you're flying today i'm flying into
venita municipal airport so i'll begin
all my radio calls with veneta traffic
and end with veneta now if you're
wondering why we do that take a quick
glance at the vfr sectional notice my
c-tap frequency is 122.9
then if you glance to the right here
you'll notice that there's another one
right beside it with the same frequency
so you can see how this could be a
problem if i just said this over the
radio skyhawk 3148 x-ray left base 170.
if someone's over at south grand lake on
left base they're going to be sweating
bullets if they heard that so by saying
the name of the airfield before and
after it helps us avoid confusion okay
so the first recommended radio call we
should be making at non-towered
airfields is prior to taxi and that
might sound something like this the
ninja traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray taxiing
from the east side hangers to 107 bonita
now while this might seem like the least
important of the recommended radio calls
you have to think some taxiways are not
visible in the hangard areas for example
you can't really see the main taxiway
from where this airplane's sitting so a
radio call might keep someone from
whipping around that corner and remember
small airplanes don't have reverse at
least none of them i'm aware of anyways
next you should be making a radio call
prior to entering the runway and that
means before you cross the vfr hold line
which looks like this also be sure to
look over and make sure nobody's on
final or turning base it's really
difficult to take off when there's
another airplane on top of you that
radio call should sound something like
this bonita traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray
taking runway 170 for a south departure
venita make sure you say which runway
you're taking and your intentions once
you take off my intentions here are to
depart to the south but if i was going
to stay and do some pattern work i might
say this instead vanita traffic skyhawk
3148 x-ray taking runway 170 for closed
traffic danita remember just be clear
with your intentions we're just trying
to be predictable the next call you
should be making is when you're 10 miles
out inbound for landing we need to say
our position and our intentions now i
know i'm 10 miles to the southwest and
my intentions are to enter a left
downwind for one seven so let's go ahead
and make that radio call venita traffic
skyhawk 3148 x-ray 10 nautical miles to
the southwest
2500 making a left downwind for 1-7
bonita don't forget part of your
position is your altitude notice how i
included that here let's say i'm 10
miles out and i'm not going to land but
i'm going to fly through the airspace
really i should be making a radio call
to do this as well now you don't always
have to do this it just depends on how
low you are and how close you're getting
to the airfield just use good judgment
here but here's an example for you to
hear vanita traffic skyhawk 3148xray 10
nautical miles to the southwest
2500 transiting to the east on the south
side benita before we talk about the
next ones i'd really appreciate it if
you click that like button it really
helps me out thank you next we have the
radio calls that we make in the pattern
and there's only three of these
recommended by the faa the first one is
when you very first enter the downwind
leg and that would sound like this
vanita traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray left
downwind 1-7 veneta pretty simple right
let's look at the next one the next one
is when we make our turn to base and
that should sound like this they vanita
traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray left base 170
veneta make sure you include whether
you're on left or right base that's
pretty helpful to other pilots then we
want to be sure to make our call on
final and that should sound like this
they need a traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray
final 1-7 veneta last but not least you
should make a radio call after you exit
the runway and you should do this after
you pass the vfr hold line if someone's
behind you on final that allows them to
know for sure that you're off the runway
here's what that call would sound like
the ninja traffic scout 3148 x-ray clear
runway one seven
and those are the only non-towered radio
calls that the faa recommends but let me
ask you a question
let's say i take off from runway one
seven and i hear this the ninja traffic
cherokee five one two three yankees left
crosswind one seven for ninja at this
point i don't know exactly where this
dingleberry is but i know he's somewhere
right in front of me and he's a
potential conflict so what should i do
we need to make a radio call that way
this guy knows to be looking for us too
now this is kind of my personal
technique when i think someone's a
conflict but what i usually do is i tell
them my position and then i kind of give
them some details on what i intend on
doing here's an example of what i'm
talking
[Music]
i about you someone in the comments is
gonna say you're clogging up the radios
but i don't see it that way i only do
this when i try to resolve a potential
conflict and this is the best way to do
it in my opinion and nine times out of
ten if you make a radio call like this
this guy will respond to you
[Music]
there's a lot of different situations
like this that you might run into in the
pattern so it'd be impossible to go into
every scenario but worst case scenario
just speak plain english most everyone
here is going to understand you if you
do that and that's the whole purpose in
these ctaf calls we're trying to be as
safe as possible when we fly i'll show
you one more real quick though let's say
i'm on left crosswind now for runway one
seven and i hear this
traffic cherokee two three four five
zulu entering left departure in downwind
for one seven fanita let's say i see
this guy this is what my radio call
might sound like
a traffic skyhawk 3148 x-ray left
crosswind 1-7 i've got you in sight i'll
follow you in next i'd like to draw your
attention to the beginning of the video
where i combine the bass and the final
call in this part of the video i'm
giving a lot of instruction on final
here and because of that i got my radio
call out of the way as soon as possible
so i could focus on instructing and this
brings me to an interesting point if you
ever feel overwhelmed while you're
trying to fly the airplane fly the
airplane first and get those radio calls
out as you can just remember that old
saying aviate navigate communicate it's
pretty tough to make radio calls when
you're dead next let's talk about one
more thing that's kind of handy to know
about non-towered radios and this one's
pretty cool you can actually control the
air-filled lighting by using the c-tap
at most non-towered airfields as you can
see at this airfield i can activate the
medium intensity runway lights by using
the c-tap if your airfield has these the
best way to turn these on is to click
your radio microphone seven times and
you have to do this within five seconds
when you do it turns it on at full
brightness from here if you make three
clicks of the mic you'll turn the lights
at their lowest brightness setting five
clicks of the mic would bring the
brightness up to the medium brightness
setting then we could click the mic
seven times again to bring it back up to
the highest setting and most of these
you can't really turn off they
automatically turn off after about 15
minutes did you know that you can
sometimes receive other services over
the ctaf frequency if the ctaf at your
airfield is also a unicom frequency you
can receive a few additional things
these unicom frequencies are usually
operated by the fixed based operators
located on the airfield and these are
the private businesses that sell you
fuel and other aviation services on the
field sometimes these are just ran by
the airport office and these are usually
run by like a city or a county in that
area but anyways a few things that you
could request on a unicom frequency are
fuel services weather information and
traffic advisories here's how i might
ask for weather with these guys
grand lake unicom skyhawk 3148 x-ray
request weather skyhawk 3148 x-ray
seven zero at niner recommended runway
one seven let's try a traffic advisory
real quick grand lake unicom skyhawk
three one four eight x-ray request
traffic
[Music]
rate advisory aircraft in the pattern
last car was on left downwind
then there's the multi-con frequency
anytime the c-tap frequency is 122.9
it's usually a multi-com and not a
unicom
so what's that mean to me
at airfields with a multi-cone frequency
there's no service provided on the ctaf
frequency except for the fact that you
can still get the pilot controlled
lighting as long as your airfield had it
to begin with i mean this is kind of
like the self-service register at
walmart let's take one more look at the
vfr sectional notice a lot of the
airfields out there are multi-con
frequencies multiple airports without
any kind of service and there's probably
more of these than any other ctaf
frequency and that's probably why they
call it multicom and these are probably
the most important fields to include the
airfield name when you're making your
radio calls because of that i really
hope you liked today's video if you did
you might enjoy this one as well if
weather's been keeping you out of the
plane i've got three tips to help you
improve without flying or maybe you're
struggling with your landings check this
video out i'll show you five of the
biggest mistakes and how to fix them
thanks for watching see